how you doing good so I would for both
of you you get to work in such big and
cool movies I would imagine you get
offered a lot of scripts what was it
about this script that said oh yeah I'm
doing this one well for me I got it I
got sent a script from Steven Knight who
I was big fan of that was gonna be
starting bathroom Akana hey who I know
and who I'm also a big fan of I also
liked that it you know whenever you read
something you truly don't know what's
going to happen on the next page that's
something worth paying attention to and
then the way it all came together the
total package of it the way the layers
just kind of reveal themselves pull
themselves back the way that the twists
happen and the way you're left in a
place that's so different from the
moment place that you started out and as
a film goer I really like that yeah for
me I read it and I mean I've been trying
to make decisions in choose films that
are ones that I want to see first so I
read this I'm going oh that's a bit of
20 that's what I want to see Steven who
was writing it I saw his work as a
director as well as I go this is gonna
be interesting it's different that's for
sure you don't read many like this yeah
or they don't come across any more an
adult erotic thriller like this with a
whodunit all along the way in a location
that just tastes good the movie tastes
good if it smells good and the script
felt that way too sexy it was smart it
was intriguing the surprising was
dangerous I was gonna say the thing for
me is that I've seen about I don't know
20,000 movies and I could not put this
one together
until more clues started being given you
know what I mean yeah when you're look
when you're reading that when you gets
into script like this how much is your
agent or manager telling you about the
whole plot and how much is it you just
need to read this assuming they've read
it before I'm reading it because
sometimes it comes in and we're all
reading it at the same time I I
generally like to not be told anything
going and I like to have my own
experience
I'll get teed up somewhat but for
something like this when it came
Steven Knight has a submission to me I
didn't need someone I didn't need a
governor to read it first - then say is
it of the yoke for you to read which
Makati no obvious I'll read it
immediately
they must looking forward to it and it
stood up I talked to Stephen a few times
and just the other day I spoke to him
he's the most calm and nice person did
he ever get did you ever see him raise
his voice once no that's not his way I
don't I couldn't tell you why it's not
his way but he's the most gentle kind
almost pure person are so elegant and
then out of his mind
comes these incredibly dark characters
in these desperate circumstances and I
don't know how he's able to live his
life with so much gentility while his
brain is clearly fascinated by all this
darkness they don't know when he's not
really connected in time in space that's
true - that's right no way I think which
that's a prescription for never raising
your voice because what the hell does it
matter anyway
or what whoa what situation could be
dire enough have to raise your voice you
know I mean he takes it as part of the
that's a pull well that's part of the
music of the day or the music of the
moment and and let's look around and
everyone play that play it where it
ladies
[Music]